تصاعد ملحوظ للضربات الاسرائيليه على
اهداف في قلب العاصمه السوريه دمشق
استهداف صاروخي تخترق به اسرائيل الاجواء
السوريه بهدف الوصول لمواقع ومنشات
وعناصره تابعه لايران الاستهداف الثاني
خلال العام الجاري هجوم صاروخي اسرائيلي
طار كفر سوسه الحي السكني في دمشق وراحه
ضحيته 15 شخصا وفقا للمرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان تلك الصواريخ الاسرائيليه استهدفت
مواقع تتمركز فيها ميليشيات ايرانيه وحزب
الله اللبناني ويعد هذا الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي ثاني خلال العام الجاري ففي
الثاني من يناير الماضي قتل سبعه عناصر
جراء الضربات الاسرائيليه على مطار دمشق
الدولي ومحيطه
وتيره الهجمات الاسرائيليه على اهداف داخل
سوريا وثقها المرصد السوري بحوالي 32
استهدافا خلال العام الماضي وحده قامت
خلالها اسرائيل باستهداف الاراضي السوريه
سواء عبر ضربات صاروخيه او جويه اسفرت عن
اصابه وتدمير نحو 91 هدفا عسكريا